des navires de pêche contraints de
rester à quai une machine à glace à
l'arrêt depuis plusieurs jours et un
capitaine au chômage technique
nous sommes au port de pêche du marin ça
va faire à deux semaines presque 3
maintenant voilà qu on est coincé à
terre ça arrive souvent cédé qu'à une
panne de machine center c'est surtout
quand ça tombe bien en ce moment ça
tombe dans une période où il ya beaucoup
de ton et la perds du temps c'est une
fois dans l'année à case-pilote la
machine à glace a récemment été remise
en état après une peine de 6 mois ne
fait pas des castings ap abel bonnard il
ya le monde adore cracher de la lave a
travaillé dur à dire mais il y a
lassé par ces pannes à répétition
l'association des marins pêcheurs de la
commune a choisi il y un an d'investir
dans une petite machine à glace mais
elle est souvent prise d'assaut là en ce
moment au niveau de la botte de nos
carrières
c'est la seule machine qui
qui fonctionnent ces périodes qui une
période de pic de production
c'est le moment où tous les machines de
la martinique devait continuer
normalement à bord du meilleur co 2 les
hommes embarquent cinq à sept jours pour
aller pêcher en haute mer et ce jusqu'à
trois fois dans le mois
la marchandise est ensuite vendue dans
le bourg de bellefontaine pour le plus
grand bonheur des clients chaque départ
en mer nécessite environ quatre tonnes
de glace que l'équipage se procure lui
aussi à case-pilote dans le bon c'est
une grosse organisation la machine est
petit
pas facile beaucoup de jaude atteinte il
faut s'organiser
des fois la machine ne fonctionne pas
bien donc c'est alternant mais bon c'est
pas facile hein c'est pas facile
la remise en service de la machine a
quelque peu soulagé des marins pêcheurs
du coin mais pour combien de temps